you
[Music]
this week marks the 50th anniversary of
the assassination of dr. Martin Luther
King jr. a new CBS News poll out just
this morning shows 53 percent of
Americans believe only some of dr.
King's goals have been achieved we'll
examine dr. King's legacy all this week
but we'll begin today with remembering
Martin Luther King jr. the father only
on CBS Michelle Miller spoke with his
children for their first joint interview
in 12 years Michelle is in Birmingham
Alabama where King led some of his most
successful nonviolent protests against
racial inequality back in 1963 Michelle
good morning good morning well dr.
Martin Luther King jr. was both a pastor
and a father of four young children
during those protests to liberate
Birmingham Martin the third Dexter and
Bernice were just 10 seven and five
years old when the father died five
years later but the trauma of April 4th
1968 still haunts them Martin and I were
watching television and even to this day
when I see a breaking news flash I I
have PTSD and you you see your father
being shot on television that that's
very very traumatic dr. Martin Luther
King the apostle of non-violence and the
civil rights movement has been shot to
death in Memphis Tennessee
I remember us going back to mother and
dad's room to get an explanation from
her I don't know that she said your
daddy has been shot
what I remember her saying was your dad
has gone home to live with God have you
grieved in the way that we all grieve
the loss of a loved one all of us to an
extent have not fully had the chance to
grieve I modeled my mom our mom was so
stoic and she held everything together
for all of us to be strong but as a
child when you emulate that in a real
sense your whole
in your emotions have you let go I'm
still working on it
it's almost a lifelong process my first
real moment was on a retreat with our
youth how old were you I was 16 laid out
over a bed for two hours I kept saying
why you know why like why did you leave
me why why did you you know take him did
you blame anyone
I was angry with God because I felt he
could have stopped it I was angry at my
father you know for leaving me I was
angry at white people because I felt
like they were responsible and I didn't
know at the time whether I was angry at
my mother and me
eventually I realized I had anger at
everybody I want to show you something
Mike Wallace young sitting down with
your family the Christmas after the
assassination of your father do you ever
have any difficulties because you are
Martin Luther King sometimes I have
difficulties one time not too long ago a
boy it was teasing me about my name too
good now and what do you want for
Christmas money a bicycle what did that
bring back to you watching that that
interview every time I see something out
of our childhood I kind of longed for
that time period where we don't have to
have so much responsibility you were
very close
yeah as kids we were yeah are you in a
good place now
was there a rift I don't think that I
can recall that there was a time that we
got to the place where we never spoke to
each other
I think publicly you have to be allowed
to work through and navigate through
your challenges did you have to lose
your father for the nation in the world
to appreciate him the way they do today
I had to do it all over again what I
want my dad here I would say no no our
world is in a better place because our
father gave his life
yes I walked through yeah they had here
dad they're having him you know to ask
the tough questions when I'm going out
on a date or something but you know
where would our world be the king
children say they believe that their
fathers legacy has actually been dumbed
down they say that he was far more
radical in his ideas and his quest to
end racial and economic inequality not
to mention the Vietnam War and it's of
course Gayle you know that it was his
support for those striking sanitation
workers that led him to Memphis in 1968
and ultimately to his death yeah I still
remember now looking at the newsreel it
says I am a man where he went to to to
advocate on behalf of the sanitation
workers but it's great Michelle that you
got all three of them to sit down
together you very rarely see that with
the three of them that's really nice yes
they have their healing and they're in a
good place as they said all right
Michelle thank you very much we all hear
about Martin Luther King for some people
he's just a name he's just a speech but
you forget he was a father and it was
interesting to hear what his children
hear Bernice even said she was angry
with him too moving